no your other speaker saying hi I guess
it's time to start hi everybody
how's it going having a good conference
so far
I guess it's getting down to the end
there's only a few around the sessions
left right well thank you all for coming
to learn about web authentication and
phyto and making authentication more
secure because what's more exciting than
that especially on Friday so before I
get into the real content let me tell
you a little bit about myself the person
on stage up here hi I'm Jen I am a
security advocate at Google and I work
on cloud platform and in this role what
I get to do is spend my time doing
research around mostly around
low-hanging fruit for helping software
developers write more secure software
and deploy to more secure ways and come
to events like this and get to talk to
you all about it run workshops give
talks things like that and another half
of my job is taking feedback from all of
you and working with my engineering
teams to make our products better making
it easier to make right decisions around
security so I love hearing from all of
you if you have any feedback comments
questions complaints about cloud
platform or anything like that I'd love
to hear from you please feel free to
reach out to me the easiest way to get
my attention is probably a direct
message on Twitter MIM encodes or if
you'd like to contact me via another
means there's gen dot run will forward
to my home page and there's a bunch of
links at the bottom to different social
channels if you prefer but enough about
me let me take this opportunity to ask
all of you some questions since we have
a nice end of an audience how many of
you are already using web authentication
or Fido security keys yourself only a
few people okay great
great hopefully I'll convince its more
of you that to start using them how many
of you have been involved in a phishing
incident at some point in your tech
career either yourself I know no one
want to admit that or cleaning up from
someone else at your organization pretty
painful isn't it
or how many of you have an open source
project like on github or get lab that
other people use in production would it
be a bummer of someone compromised that
accounts and like hid a little and I
guess looking commit and there they had
some malware there'll be a bummer it's
okay cuz you'll be safer after today so
let's talk a little bit about
authentication let's set kind of some
grounding and talk about authentication
which can kind of get people a little
excited sometimes opinions come out but
let's take a look at it from kind of a
threat modeling perspective so this is
the state of the art of authentication
as of like the 1960s and 70s and maybe
even a little further back login and
password the time of account creation
you specify a secret and then you use
that secret from your memory to identify
yourself in the future the secret share
between your brain and the server
somewhere else a different computer and
passwords are great kinda although they
won't seem to die one of the reasons is
just how easy they are to deploy if you
have a way for someone to express their
login their identity they probably have
a way to express their password too
which is why it's the first thing we're
always going to kind of deploy in a lot
of situations but even way back in the
day we started identifying problems with
passwords we wanted passwords that would
unique way to help people uniquely
identify themselves but they pick things
that were easy for them to remember like
these these were super common passwords
way back in the day and they're also
some of the most common passwords
roughly today they're still these are
from 2016 and 2017 but these passwords
are both still in the top five which we
can get from you know password breaches
so people are still using these kinds of
passwords but even years ago we came up
oh yeah and the threat that we're kind
of we want to prevent with this
situation is guessing we don't want
people to use passwords like password or
one two three four five six because
we're afraid that someone will guess
that past or at least this was the
common threat we were concerned about
long ago and in this situation we have a
user logging in with their login and
their very simple password and their
login is not a secret at all it might be
their their email address or their name
somewhere
evasion of public identity about them so
what an attacker can do is find out
their login and then guess their
password and get access to the service
but it's okay because even way back in
the day we figured out ways to try and
reduce and mitigate this risk we came up
with things that were easy to implement
in code that hopefully convince people
and guided them towards better passwords
passwords that were harder to
brute-force oh we also told people to
never write passwords down which it's
kind of a funny thing because you know
you wouldn't want someone searching
their desk and physically gaining access
to their office to then access their
system cuz we were we're dealing with
different threats back then and we hoped
the people would come up with passwords
like this like this password I got out
of a password manager recently lots of
randomness in here lots of entropy very
difficult for somebody to sit down at my
desk and guess but the code we
implemented was only so sophisticated
and people came up with their own ways
of working around it I mean how many of
you have added like a capital letter and
an exclamation mark to a password to
make it pass one of these filters a lot
of us have yeah a lot of sigh have to it
turns out that these maybe helped the
guessing a little bit but the truth is
even if people use very secure passwords
they would have trouble remembering
these so they started reusing them
across multiple providers and our threat
changed a little bit they wouldn't use
them just one site they'd use it in ten
sites all their sites that have a high
security password a low security pastor
and maybe a few classes of passwords but
times changed the internet became a
thing and we ended up with more accounts
than ever and some of those accounts
ended up in situations that got breached
and now you can go out and you can go
buy from people in the dark web
databases of literally billions of
credentials of login and password
combinations which is crazy and these
are usually like glommed together from
multiple breaches across many
organizations so you end up in a
situation where credential stuffing is a
much bigger risk than password
brute-force guessing
because people have folder advice and
come up with an amazingly secure
password and reused it everywhere they
use it in a service that service gets
breached
maybe that service use plaintext
password storage it should be awful or
maybe somebody spent a lot of time
reversing those passwords from those
hashes either way
hackers bought that information and then
they use it in a whole bunch of other
services and even though like company
XYZ may have like gotten the user to
change that password that user may have
been using the same password an email
account or a frequent flyer account they
forgot about a long time ago and
attackers can do all sorts of bad
hijinks with it and ironically if the
user had just not followed our advice
and written that down in a notebook that
they kept with them all the time
credential stuffing would be much
smaller of a threat yeah but it's okay
because we had another way to mitigate
that we had a technology called one-time
passwords one-time passwords are great
the idea behind it is in addition to the
password you ask the user for a one-time
code that is delivered to them by a
secure way either like sent to them by
an SMS and thereby you're guaranteeing
that like they're holding that phone
that has that phone number on it
which is pretty good or maybe you shared
a secret ahead of time and you can
generate new one-time passwords together
over time using cryptography or maybe
you carry around a device that was sent
by the the provider like we had these
for a long time I remember back in the
day just have a big fistful of these one
for each account and these are great but
they actually don't protect against a
new rising I guess an old but rising in
sophistication threat so one-time
passwords are great they protected
against credential stuffing they protect
against weak passwords but they actually
don't help that much against
contemporary phishing attacks in a
phishing attack we have our user wanting
to log into the service but instead a
hacker spins up a fake service that
closely resembles the real service and
then they convince the user either
through social engineering through
targeted emails or just like three
scattershot approach to sending out
thousands and thousands of untargeted
emails anyway they get some number
users to log into that service and even
if the user is using a one-time password
the attacker can still take that
information and forward it to the real
service and use automation to like
disable one-time passwords and change
passwords and cause all sorts of casts
so although one-time passwords make it a
little harder to do the phishing attack
fishing especially sophisticated
phishing is still a really big threat it
one-time passwords don't help that much
and the fundamental issue behind it the
fundamental challenge we're facing is
that we don't have some telepathic way
of communicating our shared secret to
the server we have to go through a user
interface and whenever we have to use
the user interface us as humans have to
judge whether that's real and that's
it's a lot of cognitive load especially
at a time where we might have other
stressors other things on our mind
phishing attacks are surprisingly
effective unic even against technical
even a security engineer some of these
if you manage to catch the person at a
time when they're very weak or you
manage to find a way to you know develop
a sophisticated enough fake page that
they you know they don't guess it so
what we need to do to solve this problem
is we need a way to reduce the cognitive
load on our users we need to make it
easier for them to make the right
decisions and we can do that with
technology and that's where web Bothan
and Fido Keys come in they reduce the
amount of cognitive load or users have
to do they reduce the amount of
judgement calls they have to make so
that we can securely authenticate them
and it also protects against a bunch of
other things too so let's spend the rest
time talking about that I'm gonna spend
a little bit of time talking about the
solution in a very abstract sense and
then work our way out towards
concreteness I'm gonna talk about the
protocol a little bit and then in the
most concrete form I'm gonna talk about
how you can use these to protect
yourself and protect your open source
code protect your email accounts and
finally how you can add support to your
software so that your users can protect
themselves too and then you don't have
to deal with a phishing incident from a
customer or a colleague or something
like that so first in the most abstract
sense
let's talk about how math can help save
us because math is awesome right so it
all comes back to public key
cryptography rather than sharing a
single secret we're gonna use public key
cryptography to help us authenticate
users and just to kind of recap because
I'm sure we're all familiar with all the
key cryptography but the gist of how it
works is because of some oddities of
mathematics we can generate these keys
that come in pairs a private key a
public key or in this case a yellow key
and a green key and these keys have a
special property is when you take a
message and you encode it with one key
it is only decodable with the other key
and the algorithms we use also star
bi-directional so if I encode something
with the other key the green key I can
only read it if I have the yellow key
which is great and all it allows us like
obviously it allows us to securely
transport information but how does this
help us with authentication well let's
go through that there's gonna be kind of
a two-phase process first we're gonna
have to do registration and this is
gonna come up over and over again
throughout the rest of talk and then
once we successfully register then we're
gonna do authentication so let's talk
about how public key cryptography how we
use registration and then authentication
to be able to identify people later so
here's kind of the the most like simple
version of the registration Nance we
have the user and the user has the
service they want to use the user
generates a key pair a green key and a
yellow key and then they take one of
those keys and decide that it's the
public key and then they transmit it to
the server hopefully over a secure
Channel and the server remembers that
green key
so great we've now registered we've have
given one key to the server and we kept
one key the yellow key we're going to
keep private and keep that secret
because that's what the server is going
to use to identify us so then later when
we authenticate whether the server does
is it takes the green key recalls it and
remembers it like it looks up the key
for that user and then it generates
some random string of stuff which it
calls a challenge
it takes that challenge send them back
over the wire to our user our user takes
that challenge encodes it using their
private key transmits it back over to
the server and then the server can use
the the green key to unlock the green
lock decode the message and verify that
the challenge is the same the signature
matches the the challenge it sent and
what this does it guarantees that we are
the same user as before or more
specifically that we are the user that
has the yellow key and if the user was
successful at keeping that yellow key
private we've now successfully
authenticated the user without having to
transmit that shared secret back and
forth yay success but of course the
Devils in the details we'll be getting
more into that it's a little more
complex than just this so let's get into
some of those details so to actually
make this work in reality we're going to
need a couple of different things we're
going to need some hardware because
doing cryptography on paper although
possible is very very difficult and
error-prone so we need some harder to
actually do the cryptography for us and
we're going to need a protocol so that
we can communicate that securely from
our cryptography hardware out to the
server and back and forth we need a way
to communicate that back and forth so
first let's spend a little bit of time
talking about the hardware hardware
comes in many different flavors the most
common one you're gonna see which has
been around for a little bit longer is
these tiny little dongles little USB
dongles that you plug into USB port
maybe leave it in there and then they
expose themselves to the computer is a
human interface device so it can
transmit information to the computer
they can also use near-field
communication for communicating with
mobile phones just like tap Tepeyac so
just tap to do you know cryptographic
stuff
and if all else fails we always have the
Bluetooth transport which is not as
ideal it's a little bit clunky but it's
the only option that works on iOS today
but one of the cool things is starting
to emerge is we don't have to carry
around those dongles necessarily because
now we all have Hardware either on our
mobile phones or our laptops they have
these cool hard secure Hardware enclaves
like they have special reserved pieces
of places of hardware that are
especially hardened for the purpose of
doing cryptography so that even if
someone gets malware on the computer
it's going to be very difficult for them
to extract information from that secure
Hardware Enclave and these also have the
added bonus of biometric security or
some other way of unlocking that secure
hard round clave so that I can do that
signature and what's cool about web
authentical security keys are always
probably gonna be the most secure
because it's very difficult you know
once I compromise the computer then I
have to find another way to compromise
the keys itself to get in and the
hardware in these is very simple and
easier to secure I think that these are
gonna be a lot easier the platform
authenticators are going to be much
easier to roll out at organizations so
yeh way to make it easier so now that we
have hardware that can do the
cryptography now we need a protocol we
need a way to communicate that back and
forth and this is where you kind of get
hit by the jargon bomb if you're
researching this there's a lot of
acronyms they come involved here there's
Fido which is faster than the online the
organization there's web bots and
there's you to after seat app there's so
many different acronyms so let's try and
put some of these in since I come from
context so Fido
stands for fast identity online it is
both the organization of many people
from different companies and different
standards is a standards body
essentially and they have protocols the
Fido protocols Fido to is the name of
the overarching set of protocols that
make this all possible so fast identity
online - if you search for that you'll
find like a very wide widest group
description it's a big bucket the
umbrella term I guess and Fido - we have
our user and they have a server that
they want to access within the specs is
always going to be called a relying
party you're gonna see relying party RRP
come up all the time it just means the
server is doing the authentication
they have authenticators on these are
good either going to be removable
authenticators which is basically a way
to describe those security dangles that
are USB or NFC and there's also platform
authenticators which in the spec is also
referred to as built-in sometimes when
you're communicating between the
Authenticator and the computer or the
user you're using a protocol called C
tap which is a low level essentially
wire protocol there's two versions of C
tap right now there's C tab one which is
also a subset of the older u2f protocol
so if you find yourself like buying one
of those USB devices and it advertises
you to F it's probably using the C tap
one protocol there's a newer C tap two
protocol which adds a few more bells and
whistles it adds a little bit more
persistence on the key that's required
and it's uses a slightly more convenient
encoding format but they're both they're
both very secure so your C tap one you
twelve keys are still awesome and
reverse compatible with the newer
specification and then finally web auth
n web offense the interaction between
the relying party we yeah relying party
and the user on the user on their device
and the reason you're gonna see this
come up a lot is because if you're
implementing if you're rolling this out
in your software all the code you're
gonna write is gonna be dealing with the
web authentical that's a standard you're
gonna have to look at those are the
libraries you want to use unless you're
building your own security key from
scratch you probably don't need to worry
too much about the details of the see
tap protocol being used but if you want
you totally can it's also in a fight of
standard dock a little bit harder
reading though okay so there hopefully
that dispels some of the jargon bomb web
offense seems to be the the emerging
like word that's attached to like the
newer devices fight or two has not
caught on quite as much but you'll see
multiple things in like a lot of like on
a security camera has met and stuff okay
so we have the hardware we have the
protocol let's first help me achieve my
number one goal which were the
developers out there were the most
technical people in a lot of people's
lives we should be setting the example
by doing strong authentication so I'm
gonna slow down the pace a little bit
and I'm gonna show you in painful detail
how you can use it to protect yourself
so the first thing is you need to get an
Authenticator there are a whole bunch of
different vendors for authenticators if
you just search like the web you can
probably find two or three hundred
different authenticators now here are a
few different manufacturers that I think
are kind of cool the first one that
comes to mind one of the leaders in the
space is you be Kyle they make keys that
support you to eff Fido see tap one and
what about that webathon they also have
a lot of other bells and whistles so if
you really want to get into the space
and you want to do like all the
smartcard stuff and you want to like do
GPG signing and like use the smart card
ssh stuff to do your SSH keys the ub
keys are great for that there's also
solo keys which is a fully open source
one which i think is pretty awesome and
they're also the cheapest way to get a
USBC key right now so if you want to buy
a whole bunch of USBC keys to roll out
to your organization solo keys are
probably the cheapest way to do it and
Google we have our own kit which is
comes with two different authenticators
and the idea here is you have their
backup that comes with it and we also
include a Bluetooth key so that you can
use it on all platforms including iOS so
they all work pretty much everywhere
with the exception of a couple sites
that are very yubico specific stuff but
they generally work pretty much over so
you need to get a key also since you're
in the conference today if you stop by
the Google cloud platform booth after my
talk I will have keys so low keys to
giveaway if you promise to use them okay
so now you've got your hands on some
hardware next you want to register on
important sites and now I'm going to
drag you through registration and
authentication on to providers versus
github because a lot of us have open
source software we don't I don't want
that kid I don't want supply chain
attacks becoming more common we should
all be using multi factor auth and
strong authentication under github so
here's a little screencast in the corner
you can see a little camera pointed at a
security key and you can see that I'm
logged into github right now so you have
a security
key and you want to set it up on github
you log in you go to settings go over to
security on github you have to have
already setup two-factor authentication
to add a security to add a security key
so I've already done this ahead of time
so setup two-factor authentication if
you haven't please do that right away
that will cause a security key option to
appear you go over there you tap Add and
it'll bring you past a bunch of warnings
about not getting yourself locked out
you can just ignore those scroll right
past them and register a new device you
want to give it a name cuz github is
awesome and supports multiple security
keys for each account click Add and then
it will do the registration dance the
key will start blinking or some other
indication you tap it and it's
registered yay ok you are now protected
at this point if you ignore those
warnings you want to go read them and
set up a backup method of authentication
or register a second key but when it's
time to log in you'll log in with your
username with your password and you get
an extra step which is insert your
security key if you lost it you can go
to a fallback method but it'll start
blinking you tap the key and you're
logged in yay and you're super protected
ok one more google accounts because
think of all email encounter something
you definitely want to protect and a lot
of different email providers support it
now and that's because a lot of your
password resets your backup
authentication for a whole bunch of
services you use probably relies on your
email being secure so there's something
some you use Gmail let's take a look at
protecting your Google Account this
would also work of your GCP account user
you definitely want to protect those
those accounts that have super admin
permissions everywhere so we're gonna go
click on security and what's cool about
this is we got to put in our password
and this is just to protect you from
people coming up and registering a
security key with your account when you
step away from your desk but anyway when
you go to set a two-factor it will try
and steer you towards using a phone
because that's the most convenient way
for a lot of people but there's a little
drop-down and you can pick security key
and you can actually do this as your
only form of two-factor authentication
if you want to be super secure you can
just use security keys and it's can I
use do the same process it'll start
blinking yay you give it a handle I'm
gonna call it Han because this is so
lucky
and Google supports multiple security
keys so this is the point where you
might want to add an additional security
key as a backup and then put it
somewhere safe or get your backup codes
or your secondary you know your backup
authentication method and now that we're
registered we can go ahead and log out
and verify you don't give the
authentication a quick check so let's go
ahead and sign out that's clear that
stuff from it to make sure it asks us
for the security key let's log in again
to the test account log in our username
and password we get this prompt from the
browser to go tap our security gate we
tap it and yeah Roth indicated and if
you're using like a Google organization
like if you sweet or cloud identity for
a call platform you can actually set up
policies where you require a subset of
your users either the users that are
most sensitive or have access to the
most accounts like the people who have
access to Android signing keys if you
have a Google domain you can actually
enforce it and require them to use it
which is a great way to make sure no
one's gonna sign like rando apps which
would be a terrible thing so it's kind
of cool and there are lots of other
places you can use it too and there's
actually directories online like this
one this one's my favorite dongle off
dot info which nitro key has hiss mantra
you can put on other stuff up there like
if you use a different email provider
like fast mail fast mail supports it or
if you want to see the sorry state of
investing sites you can see that pretty
much nobody supports it which makes me
sad except for Vanguard but their
implementation has some challenges but
hey it exists cause you can go and check
all of your favorite sites all the
places you have accounts go through your
password manager take all those domains
see which ones have support and add it
but notable ones are like Twitter and
Facebook yeah those are things you might
want to add security he AWS is another
one cloud computing although there's
also only supports one security key
hopefully they change it
cool okay let's go back to the side so
yeah you go and you edit all your
services yay you're super protected now
so now you're protected you feel safe
everyone around you at your organization
or all your customers or like hey I see
you using those security keys I want to
be protected too or more likely you
decide to enforce it upon them somehow
let's talk about adding support to your
software so what I really wanted to do
was come up here and like crank out like
a 10-minute live code demo I did my best
I did a bunch of implementations with
like several different client libraries
we're not there yet so the best
implementation I came up with was using
the dual are the smallest implementation
is using duo labs is Python client
library I got down to an implementation
that resulted in the patch file of about
850 lines of code so not quite live code
ready yet but instead let me give you
some advice from having tried this with
a whole bunch of different client
libraries the first one is use a client
library you know you're dealing with
cryptography especially on the server
side
don't try and roll it yourself use a
client library the other thing is that
the client libraries are kind of new
because they like web authentic all is
been moving through you know different
levels of specifications so these
libraries are all pretty young so
whenever use cryptography libraries and
production proceed with caution
most of these haven't reached 1.0 yet
make sure you give them significant
amounts review and take your time so
make sure you set aside time to do it
but this list is from web auth and I Oh
which is a website maintained by duo
labs I believe and it is a great site
that links to a curated list of client
libraries which is a pretty good list of
client libraries so that's a good place
to start to your search for client
libraries that match your infrastructure
and your you know your code best and
then once you have a client library it's
time to start implementing stuff there's
a wonderful site out there also
maintained by duo labs that is just so
awesome that rather than like
reimplemented stuff on my own slides I'm
just going to drag you through the site
this
is web authentification zit is probably
the most succinct explanation of
webathon I've seen so far so let's
scroll past all the pretty graphics and
let's talk about registration and
authentication so here's a little
cartoon that kind of describes the
process similar to the stuff we showed
earlier where you have either a new
account or though more commonly you're
probably gonna have an existing account
that's already authenticated and you
want to add a key to it although for
some reason most of the demos assume
you're doing it at a time of account
creation I don't think that that's
realistic but just whenever you see new
account in a demo or a documentation
just assume that's like adding a key to
an existing account but essentially what
you're going to do is send a request out
to the user and then they're gonna send
a public key and then you're gonna do a
wonderful process to verify that so when
the user says they want to register a
key
you're gonna call this method this part
of your browser API navigator dad
credentials that create and here it
looks all cute and nice it's actually
kind of a little bit a safe you guys got
some got some edges it's not as simple
as just passing in a single parameter
because we want flexibility and this is
actually what it looks like when you
call the method there's this big old
blob of configuration information that
you're sending up to the browser so the
browser can make that call successfully
and there's a few different things
you're packin into there the first one
is that challenge even during
registration you want to do a challenge
that you can verify that the user
actually has that private key but one of
the things is weird about the challenge
is the challenge has passed the API you
can't just give it a base64 encoded
string or a string or something nice
like that you have to give it an array
of integers I guess because it makes it
easier to communicate to the key so you
want to encode that so gonna be doing a
little munging you're going to include
information on the relaying party
relying party sorry you your name is
actually required you'd have to give a
human readable name this shows up on the
dialog in the browser and then you give
an ID which has to match the domain name
the origin from which
this came so if you sent this out via
JavaScript or you burned it into the
page it's gonna have to match whatever
is on the browser at that time and it'll
also have to be stable because you're
gonna use it during authentication you
also have to tell the user a little bit
about themselves you have to give an ID
is required field and in all the
browsers the spec is a little bit loose
here but from all that from Firefox and
chromium based browsers and then I
played with it generally has to be a
it's again it is a an array of integers
but it's used this kind of encoding it
seems to only work if you give it off
the numeric characters I'm letting off
but if you throw out signs or stuff
outside
you know extended character sets it
seems to get kind of cranky so you have
an ID
I guess typically this is gonna be a
numeric ID from your database name is
actually their login it's not actually
their name so whatever the login they
use either an email address or their
login identifier and then you're
actually required to send a display name
up with the user you can use an email
here if you don't have a display name in
your account and then one thing that's
kind of funny is the spectacle OTT about
an icon see you the the keys I got a
little bit of trivia the keys are
encouraged support storing up to 128
bytes of profile icon information for
the users but I'm not exactly sure why I
need to figure out who got that out of
the spec and asked them but it's
technically optional although most of
the client libraries just flatten it
down to an empty string the empty
strings work here you need to tell it
what different algorithms you can
support and you have this like encoding
you have to use for the algorithms these
are the different cryptographic
algorithms you want to support and if we
go to the spec we can actually see
there's three different algorithms that
are required to be supported by the keys
which is what everyone supports today
let's find those so the easiest thing to
pass in is just negative 7 negative 257
and negative 37 if you don't care
they'll pretty much guarantee it's gonna
work for all the keys that are out there
today if there are keys that support
other encryption algorithms I haven't
found them and I buy all the ones I can
I can find I haven't gotten anyone any
key to respond
anything but those three but they all
respond to all three so what else are we
sending up Authenticator selection you
can specify whether you want to use a
built-in Authenticator or cross-platform
one of those dongles you can leave this
is optional I typically don't care what
doth enter Gator people are using so you
can leave this out entirely timeout is
technically optional but it's really not
the default timeout and chromium based
browsers are super short like I don't
know if it's a second or less than a
second but it seems to happen pretty
much instantly so specify a timeout and
that's just how long they have to put
the button on the key before it like
says hey you ran out of time and a test
ation so you've a few options here
direct will give you detailed
information about the key they've
inserted which does compromise users
privacy a little bit you might be able
to use it to track the user to some
extent but this is useful if you are in
I can enterprise and you want to make
sure that they are only using the keys
you gave them you can whitelist certain
key providers or if you want to like
blacklist keys that are manufactured in
a certain place or something like that
you would set this to direct and you
would use that to filter the keys that
people are allowed if you set it to none
people can use any key and for a lot of
consumer base stuff I would just set
that to none okay so then you finally
get all that data information up there
you you munge it into the right by and
you know that the integer arrays and you
send it to the method the credentials
that Krane and it'll run and it'll give
you back stuff that looks like this this
is what will come back out it'll be
returned and you get a cool bunch of
data back in a convenient format of an
array buffer binary data I guess it
comes right off the key and right back
into your into your code which is great
because you have to communicate that
back to the server and it's always fun
to communicate random binary data back
to the server so generally what you're
gonna do is you're gonna base64 encode
this send it back to the server somehow
I'm either by like a combination either
basically for encoding it and sending it
over like a JavaScript request or you
can actually bake it into the full bake
it into a form and submit it the spec
doesn't actually care how you get it
back to the server you just got to get
it back somehow then when you're back on
the server there are a couple chunks of
information that are going to come back
out
the challenge is gonna come back you
want to verify that challenge matches
and challenge you sent the origin you
want to make sure that this didn't
change and flight somehow that it
matches your domain name and actually
there is the full process is in the spec
is a nineteen point procedure which is
why you want to use a client library
because it makes it like a one-step
process you're going to spend some time
decoding it because you got back like
basic ste foreign code of stuff you're
going to decode it and then at the end
of the day you end up with a bunch of
cool information that you want to save
some of the notable information is going
to come back that you want to keep is a
credential ID and this is going to be a
real long string which identifies the
key so it's actually the combination of
your information your origin and the and
the keys private key so it's generated
for each service independently but for
you that identifiers defined identifies
that key it'll be stable so when you
later want to recall that key you want
to store that and of course you get the
public yet you want to use that because
that's the whole point having that green
key and you get back some other
information you can use to verify like
the the encryption algorithm support it
and stuff and easier required to store
but I would also recommend that if you
used any interesting options up here
store all of that with the key record
also because when you do authentication
you're gonna need to recall some of that
information so like if you requested
class platform only and all that stuff
you want to store that information up
back in the database to okay so at this
point assuming that nineteen point check
being handled by your client library it
was successful you now have a registered
user you can store that key please
support multiple keys so at this point
you can you know store it in a separate
table or a separate object in your
database and then yeah your user is
protected okay so now that we have that
key stored the authentication which is
actually a little bit of a longer comic
book whoa it's actually a little bit
easier to implement in code at the time
the user signs in you're going to check
to see if you have a key for that user
if you have a key for that user you're
going to send them some information to
configure that create
you'll get requests they're going to
sign the challenge and send it back to
you so let's see what that looks like in
code again you have a nice method that
just deceptively simple when you just
list it here but again you have to take
some information from the server and
send it back up you have a challenge
again that you you generate on the
server server needs to keep track of
this at least for the duration of the
session you send it up it has to be
converted into a array of integers again
and then allow credentials so their
credential ID what you send up as you
send up an array of all the keys so if
you if the if the user has one or three
or five keys you're going to send up
information for each one of those keys
in the order you can optionally specify
in the order of preference although none
of the browser's seem to do anything
with that yet so those credential IDs
come back out and you send them back up
and you can optionally specify
transports at this point I don't know
why you can't specify this during
registration but you could optionally
restrict them to only transmit it over
NFC or USB if you want to ban Bluetooth
or something like that but there's one
cool thing that is optional here which
I'm gonna go over and look at the spec
again which is not in this particular
but there is another optional field
called user verification and this one's
pretty cool so defaults to preferred but
you can actually require user
verification and what that means is it
will only allow the request to work if
the user verifies your identity locally
in a reasonably secure way this would
either be by entering a pin code or more
more likely using biometric or a
password to unlock the Enclave on their
platform Authenticator this is important
if you want to do fully password to this
authentication if you want to do fully
pass with authentication and make web
botha and they're only authentication
step please use this because it will
prevent like someone finding a key on
the ground and then like doing some kind
of geography attack on like everyone who
submits you know everyone who does open
source code in a certain location this
is how you prevent that because it will
restrict it to only authenticators it
can verify the identity locally you know
kind of moving that password burden back
to their client side okay so then you
send it all up you finally call the
method and you get back another big old
blob of a whole bunch of binary data
which you have to again base64 encode
transmitted back to the server either by
stuffing an inform or making a
JavaScript request and the actual
verification is no longer a nineteen
step verification it's actually much
easier for for the authentication you
pretty much verified that the
credentials the but you you know you
verify that the challenge was signed
with the public key and then you've
pretty much verified the user the only
other step here this kind of glossed
over is there's actually a key owner
that's embedded in the keys also and the
idea behind this is it makes it easier
to detect cloned keys which I don't know
if anyone has cloned and either hardware
keys yet but if someone were to clone a
key each key keeps track of the number
of times it's authenticated if you ever
see the count go backwards that means
that there's a clone key in the wild and
you shouldn't validate that key for that
account but one of the weird things
about the spec is you don't get the
initial count until you do the first
authentication so during registration
just default to count to zero and then
you'll be setting the initial count
during the first authentication it
better be higher than zero because
that's what the spec requires and then
for every subsequent authentication you
want to make sure it increments a little
bit and with that you've now added it to
your software so as you can see we're at
a point in the spec right now where
although the client libraries will take
care of a lot of the server-side work
there's not a lot of opinions either in
the spec or in the client libraries now
about how you convey that information
back and forth to the client and you
still have to do a lot of boilerplate
encoding and decoding which was most of
that a hundred lines of code was
basically remanding these things into
like binary formats which is a bummer
because that's kind of error prone code
and it can end up in a situation where
it works but it might have problems so
take some time during your moment ations
right now
so let's talk a little realities of if
you were to try and implement it today
one of the first questions that comes up
all the time is what about lost keys cuz
likes it all that my users have a
physical device I don't want them to get
locked out that's a total pain to deal
with and this is the first thing that
comes to her mind but it's actually not
as big of a problem as you would expect
because we already have a lot of
workflows in place we're dealing with
this exact problem because people like
even when it's tough even when they're
not using a physical key to authenticate
people still lose their phones they use
for their one-time passwords people
still forget their passwords we have
backup methods so it's no different for
for this rely on that backup method if
you're doing a consumer facing service
as an IPA password reset email or a key
reset email if you're at an under
Preiser organisation this might have
them come in to the help desk and say hi
and verify that they look like their
badge photo use whatever backwards are
you know whatever fallback methods you
have and I agree that this can pose a
degradation and security this is kind of
like a built-in downgrade attack but the
truth is even if someone is using a
security key for 99 percent of their
authentications and they fall back that
1% of time or fall back when they're
using an iOS device they're still much
more protected because they're you know
most of our authentication czar going to
happen a situation where it's very
difficult to fish them and their spidey
sense is gonna be up like if they get a
phishing attack that tells them they
have to their security key doesn't work
like that should give them more pause
there's less cognitive load there so
Alaska is not as bad of a problem as you
might think
bigger problems are that Iowa support is
lagging right now I think this is kind
of the biggest thorn in the side of
deploying this is that people want to
authenticate their services on iOS
devices and yeah I'm hoping that they'll
kind of get on the bandwagon especially
because like so many iPhones have those
platform authenticators now a potential
platform Authenticator it's like I
really hope that this is going to based
on some of the activity in the developer
preview on Safari
it looks like they're finally getting on
board so we'll have this soon I think
that will make robots a lot easier as I
said earlier the spec is kind of young
although we've been doing stuff
essentially like this for like eight
years now the current incarnation of
spec is still
which means the client libraries are
still kind of young and as you can see
it did you have to do a good amount of
code to get them implemented I'm hoping
we end up with some client libraries in
the near future they have more opinions
about transmitting information to client
side and server side in a more cohesive
across the flow so you can really just
kind of drop something in a note will be
work pretty well we're not quite there
yet
I guess that's work that I should
probably be doing and in all of my
implementations of this so far I still
have to have the spec open in another
tab which is usually another sign that
this is still pretty young technology
and it's never terribly fun to have to
be referring back to the spec and being
like profile I can't what is that is
that really required the reality is
right now if you're doing an
implementation you're still gonna have
to be going back to the specification
we're just okay it's not it's actually
aspects Coates is pretty digestible it's
like it's like I don't like eighty or
ninety pages long which seems bad but
like the bluto spec is like 3,000 pages
so like it's actually a pretty easy to
read spec as they go so with that I
guess it's time to conclude so I want
you to remember a few things from this
talk it's that passwords and OTPs they
are not enough for a lot of kind of the
modern threats are facing phishing is on
the rise
targeted phishing attacks are happening
and developers are starting to get
targeted themselves which is bad we need
to protect ourselves so they're not
enough especially for us we should all
be using this technology because we have
the technical expertise to be able to
use it today and we have more to protect
and also like adding it to your software
isn't too bad now like I know not all of
you probably want to go jump and start
to pulling it today but it's probably a
good time to start thinking about it
start getting ready to to add this to
your software cuz the more of us editor
software you know we started hitting
critical mass and then people will start
demanding it more and then the whole
internet is more secure and we've solved
a really big threat right now which
would be great it would be great if
people didn't get fished anymore
I would like that a lot so with that
thank you so much I challenge you all
now to go out edit your software edit
your accounts and we can reduce pwnage
Internet
and here's a resource slide if you'd
like links to all the different things I
linked and all the knocks I looked at
including those awesome dual labs things
and links out to some vendors for keys
go ahead and check out the slides
there's a short link to the slides up
there too so thank you so much oh yeah
and I will be hanging out at the cloud
platform booth if you want to so low key
swing by I will be handing them out
while supplies last